okay it's probably time we talk about  this guy uh autograph Mains obviously  he's acting crazy no way an adult should  ever act a secret to this video that you  probably didn't know is that is Kate  Upton Justin Verlander's wife  is there a chance he wanted a Kate Upton  autograph  he did  he's still torso over the kids crowding  the kid looks back and he's like dude  can you just give me a break but the  reason this went viral regardless is  because he bows that kid he's up all in  the kid's face  and you gotta hope that this isn't like  an eBay guy who's gonna sell the stuff  uh I'm only gonna give this guy negative  two only because the internet was  pointing onto this guy he learned a  lesson so you know we can we can look  back and we can all work you know you  know negative two